joining us now is the actor writer
producer comedian he's Nick Kroll second
season of the big mouth that's on
Netflix yeah and a premiere is this
Friday a lot of slashes there actor
writer producer comedian Nick I know
it's almost as if I should settle on
something I you know I tell my ego that
I had to do one yeah who I think it
would be a guest on the Dan Patrick show
well done right by the way you've been
in the league sausage party adult
beginners you were an uncle drew you
were great uncle thank you very much
anywhere thanks there's a lot of fun
it's so funny and I got to hang out with
Shaq what was that like okay so you get
cast it set the scene so you get you get
the call I get a call incoming saying
they're making this movie of uncle drew
starring Kyrie Irving as his character
from the the Pepsi video internet videos
and I'd seen those videos I thought they
were super funny I remember seeing that
when it first came out not knowing who
Kyrie was and just being like this is
funny I don't I can't believe this guy's
a professional basketball player and
then started watching Kyrie and I was
like oh this is a very good professional
basketball player who also is equally
funny and then they were like and it's
gonna be Shaq and Chris Webber and Kyrie
and Reggie Miller and and Lisa Leslie
and I was like I'm in I'm in I just I
wanted to hang out I mean I was like
Shaq is straight-up
hilarious dude again I don't care
whether he's a pro basketball player or
a human being that's been scaled up 25%
the cockiest guy on the floor Pam no
reason none truly no good reason truly
no good reason and um I guess but that
was the fun of it you know
and I was on the I was a big Knick fan
growing up I was at those games I was at
the game when Reggie lit up the Knicks
was Spike Lee in the crowd you know that
that movement choking and then also
people don't talk about he pulled
another move he went he didn't go up he
went down and but I was at that game and
so to be on the sidelines talking smack
against Reggie Miller who was missing
threes I was like there's no no
[Laughter]
nothing better there's nothing better
for a guy like me tip so I had a blast
it was so fun but you also had Kyrie
find out he got traded yeah while you're
shooting the movie yeah it was really
wild it was like you know you're just to
be at a moment in time it was like
they're almost from this time last year
it was like a few weeks earlier than
this to find to be around a guy who was
at the center of in like the basketball
universe and to see kind of how he
handled it and and but to be working
with him a guy who was just gotten
traded the biggest traded I don't know
in quite some number of years I'm in
basketball and then have him come right
back to set get right back to acting and
be kind of a a gentleman through the
whole thing was I mean for me it was it
was a blast
what do you think of sports as it you
know it's a theme for a comedy for
movies I love it you have to have
authenticity yeah with sports where you
can't have a guy like John Goodman
playing Babe Ruth didn't work out well
it did he didn't look legitimate they
should have spent more time on the hot
dog eating I think that if there have
been a little more of that um yeah it's
tricky I mean it's like I mean that's
the beauty of having those guys the fact
that you could have
Kyrie on the floor and and Nate Robinson
guys who were still you know still and
all those guys and then you have to like
you know hopefully I don't ruin the
movie but I did score
Kyrie tried to block my shot and I
scored and I felt I was like pretty
psyched about that and then do you have
video yeah there is video on it if you
go to the outtakes you can find video of
it it's it's it's in the antics of the
movie and then I come back and I try to
DM up there's video of that cuz it's in
the trailer that showed the footage they
have of like let's watch Kairos just
work somebody that's me later in the and
so it's anyway but I have it was the
most fun thing in the world but I think
those movies I don't know what it is
about like I mean I'm there's a movie
called A Knight's Tale Heath Ledger I
love it's one of my favorite sports
underdog movies because it's a it's like
you know I mean it's about a jousting
yeah but it's the same there's like we
don't include that now is that the best
jousting movie of all time
check Rotten Tomatoes give me a second
okay yeah
for me it's like the I love it if I
didn't think of that as just sportsman I
think of it it says that classic sort of
underdog you know a dude movie and it's
just a grape but I think it's that when
you're trying to tell the story of a
movie there's something about the that
underdog sports movie that just works
perfectly for that journey but I didn't
you just finish Olympic dreams yes
I made a movie at the Olympics with
Jeremy Teicher and Alexei Pappas Alexei
is a summer Olympian she runs she ran
the 10k in Brazil in Rio and I think is
gonna run the marathon in Tokyo and they
got a grant from the Olympic Committee
to make a movie inside of the Olympics
in Pyeongchang so the three of us spent
like two to three weeks inside of the
Olympics in the athletes village in the
Medical Centre in the dining hall the
gyms everywhere we kind of had free
range to go wherever we wanted this is
serious that this isn't a mockumentary
or no I mean there's some comedy in
there but it's like a real kind of movie
about what it's like because Alexei has
experienced that as an Olympian what
it's like to be in the inside of the
Olympics to go to the Olympic Games and
and be one of the best in the world and
then show up and maybe you know place
xxx out of a hundred and what and what
that what that feeling is like for so
many Olympians which is you're the best
in the in your country you're the best
person from your town ever and then you
show up at the Olympics and you're like
how do I what happens now and we got to
hang out with all the skiers and meet
all the you know snowboarders and all
that stuff it was it's I don't I don't
know when it'll come out but it's a cool
experience
he's Nick Kroll the second season of Big
Mouth on Netflix premieres this Friday
big mouth is about teenage friends
upended by the wonders and horrors of
puberty it's a edgy animated comedy
Andrew Goldberg is in this yeah he
co-created with me and John Mulaney
co-stars with me yeah and it's me John
Mulaney Jason Mantzoukas who I was on
the league with my friend Jenny slate
Jessi Klein Fred Armisen Maya Rudolph
Jordan Peele plays the ghost of Duke
Ellington who haunts my house you know
what do people say to you on the street
how do you get
I get all types of things right now I'm
getting a lot of big mouths which is
nice people are psyched for the second
season
but people scream douche at me a lot
I'm not sure if it's because I've played
a douche twice or they just don't like
me but I get that a lot I played a
character named the douche on parks and
recreation there's a morning radio DJ
called crazy IRA and the douche and then
in the movie sausage party I play
literal douche everybody is a you know a
supermarket product mine was a physical
douche the feminine hygiene product
we're well aware of what typecast as a
douche it's possible you know what there
are worse things in the world as someone
said this to me early on in my career
there worse things in the world than
getting typecast cuz it means that
you're working okay so you know I guess
I'll take what I can get no matter what
that means our fans wanted to know about
the league yeah when you know we put out
our guest list yeah you know with a they
wanted to note they assume you know what
you're talking about on the league I you
know I did when we were when we were
shooting the league I was much more up
day to day on what was happening at
football we had a league inside of the
league like we had our fantasy league
going and I was pretty good at it and I
definitely was like a tinkerer like my
guy on the league was Ruxin and he was
always tinkering with his lineup we
created a thing called the
tinker-stinker it's that Sunday morning
you know depending on where you live you
get out you get on the toilet around 9
a.m. and you you do your final last
week's to ruin your lineup and that was
based that was ripped straight from the
headlines
hoo-dee-hoo came up with the leak
meaning who was on that show who came up
with the idea Oh Jeff and Jackie Schafer
Jeff Schafer and very talented very
talented dude who had been a
writer out and and showrunner on
Seinfeld eventually and and has been a
writer and director on Curb Your
Enthusiasm so he and his wife Jackie
came up with the show and then put to
put together that casts and it was sort
of using the format of what they did on
Curb Your Enthusiasm very loosely
scripted kind of big bits big ideas and
and we had a blast I think it's now it
had been offline I think it the league
has just gone on to Hulu so if people
have been itching to find it they can go
on Hulu and watch it and see me be one
of the worst human beings and you take
great pride in that I do I do
there's a lot of like my character
always thought there was collusion the
last two years has been like a lot of
people tweeting me screaming collusion
and gifts at me and I'm like I don't
know man
did you ever audition for Saturday Night
Live I did did you grew up in
Westchester I grew up in the suburbs of
the city it was in Rye New York tough
streets in Rye New York how did you get
out of Rhys I you know by hook or crook
I got out of there by select go watch
the Rangers practice the Rangers I was
practicing rye and in the Knicks
practice in SUNY Purchase and but it was
always kind of my dream to be on SNL I
finally got to audition and like right
before I went out there that like one of
the stagehands guys looked at me goes
are you gonna play Jon Lovitz and I said
I'm gonna play Lyle I'm gonna play the
the love child of Lyle Lovett's and Lyle
Lovett and Jon Lovitz and then he goes
save it for the stage and I was like
okay thanks man I guess I'll go up on
and then I went up on stage in and then
performed it was it was it went it went
okay and some room silent it's pretty
quiet even and and I get out there and
and and Lorne Michaels was sort of like
there in the bathroom and I was like
what they're outside and I go what he
was there outside I go are they out
there talking about how great I am and
he was like no and I was like all right
man
but you know it it all worked out as it
was supposed to I think I ended up on
the league the next year and I audition
the same year as John Mulaney and Jordan
Peele John got hired as a writer there
Jordan has gone on to do nothing he's
done very little Jordan I actually so we
both have created our sketch shows
similar times and there's a sketch
actually that's online of Jordan I both
playing refs basketball drafts that is I
did this character ref Jeff who was kind
of a ref who just wanted to hang out
with the players and Jordan has his
version of it and so you know it all
worked out and you're here today and
Here I am at the Dan Patrick show
yes stand-up act you ever saw well you
know I'm I'm I came up with a really a
bunch of funny people um I would you
know but but I'm trying to think I mean
right now obviously mulaney's hired up
they're wrong if you haven't seen Ali
Wong stand-up go check her out on
Netflix
I think she's doing it just about as
well as anyone right now who would you
not want to follow oh man back in the
day back in the day I mean I think it
would have been pretty hard to follow I
mean you look at like ed those Eddie
Murphy delirious era I mean I don't even
know if he was doing like spots I think
he just like like came off and just you
know popped out like a like a monster I
mean when I first started like like Zach
Galifianakis was he was the guy who I
think we were all like this guy's the
funniest guy we were talking before we
started here it's like it takes a while
for people to discover people so there
was about 10 years where we all knew
that Zach was the funniest guy and then
he gets in the hangover and everybody's
like oh that dude so funny but like
we're you know John mulaney's the same
way I went to college with John I always
knew he was the funniest guy and it's
taken everybody a little while to
realize how funny is what did you go to
Georgetown just I studied uh I was a
history major
and an art and Spanish minor but I found
improv in college I met buddies like
Mike Birbiglia there
he's got a new show on Broadway coming
out this October John Mulaney and a
bunch of other incredibly funny smart
people and and I but I I really found
comedy there I happen to be Georgetown
just at that sweet spot after Iverson
before Roy Hibbert before it was in that
sweet spot where they could barely get
into the NIT mm-hmm
but I went to John Thompson basketball
camp when I was a kid so like I was
there when I went to basketball camp
there when like morning and matumbo were
kind of right around there and I was
just like one day I'm gonna be a center
for the Georgetown basketball team
following that big man tradition it
didn't work out it didn't it didn't here
we are though and once again we're happy
that you're here with us it all worked
out yeah it is season two big mouth on
Netflix premieres this Friday
he's actors / writer / producer slash
comedian / guest on the Dan Patrick show
he's Nick Kroll thanks oh could you put
that on his IMDB it's already up oh it
is yeah okay Nick it's good to go to
visit with you Thank You Congrats on
your success thank you and good luck
with season 2 of big mouth on Netflix
premieres this Friday for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]